[Musique]
nous sommes ici en présence et alexandre
âtre templiers alexandre templiers
comment allez-vous bien merci merci
d'être venu ici à nos studios à
radio-canada pour nous parler des entre
autres de vos projets musicaux qui sont
aussi un peu des projets théâtraux je
dirais il ya du théâtre il ya beaucoup
de mise en scène aussi donc vous cette
chanteuse et pour commencer j'aimerais
parler de votre identité parce que j'ai
lus par ci par là en préparant cette
entrevue qui est vous ne vous considérez
ni ni espagnols ni flamenca ni
parisienne totalement même si vous êtes
né à paris donc comment vous feriez pour
définir ce qu'ils alexandra templiers hu
et moi moi je me sens de partout et de
nulle part en même temps c'est à dire
que je me sens bien partout en tout en
étant consciente que je n'appartiens pas
exclusivement à une culture locale
comment je me définis je dirais vraiment
citoyenne du monde c'est vraiment comme
ça je me re que je me sens j'ai grandi
avec trois langues j'ai grandi entouré
de personnes qui venaient d'horizons
très différents
j'ai eu la chance de voyager et de vivre
à l'étranger et je me définirais
vraiment comme quelqu'un de
transfrontaliers et je pense que c'est
aussi exactement ce qui apparaît dans
mon spectacle qui est interculturel
essentiellement interculturel c'est
vraiment le un des ingrédients
principaux et fondateur de ce projet et
puis de ma démarche artistique en
général aussi
donc j'imagine qu'ils vous pouvais pas
non plus vous définir comme caennaise
me diop parce que justement vous 7,7
citoyen du monde mais qu'est ce que vous
faites au canada comment vous vous êtes
rendu si on fait alors qu'il ya des
annonces
évidemment non jeu ça fait trop de temps
que je suis ici et puis quoi qu'il en
soit pour peut-être plus québécoise mais
qu'est ce qui m'a amené ici
plusieurs choses le et la mort primero
maumont
fiancé qui est qui est venu ici donc du
coup ça a été une première invitation à
venir découvrir le québec
et puis surtout de la nécessité de me
retrouver justement dans un milieu
interculturel dynamique où je pouvais
commencer à réaliser ce rêve que j'avais
depuis longtemps de rassembler tout mon
bagage qui est très varié parce que j'ai
commencé par dans la philosophie la
littérature puis le théâtre puis le
chant lyrique puis le chant flamenco
donc d'arriver à rassembler tout ce
bagage danse danse dans des créations en
fait et il me semblait qu'ici c'était un
lieu vraiment propice à ça et jusqu'à
présent je me suis vraiment pas trompé
quel quelles sont vos motivations quel
est le genre c'est faire ce que vous
faites en tant qu'artiste des vôtres
acquis qu est ce qui vous pose sa faire
ça l'urgence la nécessité ok la
nécessité elle vient d'un désir de
d'être relié aux autres d'une confiance
profonde dans la beauté dans le fait que
la beauté existe dans le fait que la
beauté n'est pas de l'ordre de l'opinion
individuelle qu'il ya une objectivité de
la beauté que la beauté permet une
connaissance aussi c'est un lieu de
connaissance c'est la garantie d'une
connaissance sur l'humain et sur le
monde
je pense que l'art c'est le lieu d'une
connaissance qu'on ne peut avoir qu à
travers l'art de même que la science
apporte une connaissance qui lui est
propre
l'art doit être conscient qu'il est le
lieu d'une connaissance qui est celle de
l'humain de l'être humain et j'ai une
confiance profonde on le fait que l'être
humain est
il est doué de sens que l'existence
humaine a un sens et que nous sommes là
pour quelque chose et que ce quelque
chose est beau et peut être beau et
c'est cette nécessité là en fait qui
guide ma ma démarche artistique
d'arriver à transmettre ça aux gens et à
réaliser ça sur ses collègues qu'on le
vive ensemble lors d'un spectacle les
titres le
dites que vous savez donner à votre plus
récent spectacle c'est le niño sonnino
säntis numéro uno
les enfants sont innocents et numéro
doubiens sept titres light quoi vous
vous l'avez choisi alors ce titre est
venu en fait deux le ski ce qui a été
vraiment le déclic pour moi de sauter à
l'eau dans cette démarche
et puis de devenir ok c'est vraiment le
moment maintenant d'arrêter de de
vouloir continuellement apprendre
apprendre à prendre mais de commencer
vraiment à me lancer dans un processus
de création vraiment personnel et le
déclic ça a été ce qui s'est passé
récemment donc au moyen-orient où j'ai
vu des images d'enfants qui avait été
bombardé et j'ai été vraiment
profondément émue et touchée par le
regard
la colère qui avaient dans leur regard
la terreur qu'ils avaient dans leur
regard et et l'incompréhension aussi
qu'ils avaient dans leur regard et il ya
eu comme un sentiment d'impuissance qui
ce qui s'accumulaient depuis des années
comme une sensation d'une envie de
hurler et là je me suis ok c'est moment
de sortir et de crier en fait et d'où le
titre tout ça c'est partie aussi du coût
d'une des premières pièces cocon à qu'on
a mis dans ce spectacle qui est une
pièce de enrique morente à les contrôler
à terme qui termine avec cette phrase
les enfants sont innocents l'audi newson
innocence
donc ça a été comme le point de départ
de mire ok là il faut vraiment sortir
écrié ensuite et c'est aussi plus large
que ça c'est à dire que l'enfance je
pense que c'est ce qui nous déterminent
tous d'une façon absolument démesuré on
se rend pas compte à quel point notre
enfance nous nous continuons à nous
guider aujourd'hui et puis il ya une
joie dans l'enfance une spontanéité en
tout cas dans mon enfance que j'ai perdu
par la suite et que j'avais envie de
retrouver
et au fur et à mesure que je commençais
à construire ce spectacle je me suis
rendu compte que la joie c'est quelque
chose d'absolument fondamentale
fondamentale il ya une phrase on utilise
des deux s'imposent de l'échantillonnage
dans le spectacle s'est pas de façon
gratuite c'est parce que je voulais
aussi que on entendre d'autres voix et
donc il ya notamment celle de pierre
rabhi qui est un agriculteur et un
philosophe français qui est une des voix
les plus importantes je pense
aujourd'hui compte tenu des changements
de paradigmes qu'il faut qu'on applique
et il dit on est dans une société de
l'abondance et on consomme des
anxiolytiques en veux tu en voilà
on n'a même pas réussi à mettre de la
joie dans cette société
et ça j'ai trouvé que c'était d'une
justesse incroyable c'est à dire qu'on a
tout mais on n'est pas heureux on n'est
pas joyeux et la joie c'est quelque
chose de vraiment extrêmement profond ça
va avec le fait d'être blanc son corps
d'être en relation avec les autres êtres
vivants en fait
et du coup c'est ça je me suis rendu
compte que la joie c'était quelque chose
de vraiment très très important et que
c'était probablement la voie explorée
pour pouvoir changer quelque chose
courte est-ce que coûte morcourt
morceaux de votre spectacle si ce que
vous voulez vous sentez à l'aise et
chanter un petit peu ici ok ok ok ok
c'est un petit morceau de de la pièce
centrale du spectacle qui qui est donc
basé sur un rythme de ses délires propre
du flamengo longs mois
un pan si gameplay
un banc lima
[Musique]
limoges les mots
moi
mon alignement lommois thon rouge si
nvidia
[Musique]
à
l'église c'est un peu tôt le matin pour
chanter mais les paroles sadi les morts
mendient toujours les morts mendient
encore ils mendient pour avoir de la
joie
il demande la joie merci alexandre
templiers merci beaucoup